I heard Lionel Richie tell a fantastic
story he he is a young performer was
um crippled uh by stage fright crippling
stage fright
uh and yet look at him today you know
this this remarkable performer and and
he says the difference between the hero
and the coward is not the presence or
absence of fear he says the difference
is they both feel fear the difference is
one steps forward and the other steps
back it's exactly right it's exactly
right you know I think I I often say
that psychological safety and courage
are two halves of the same coin right
it's it's
um in a psychological safety is that
belief that when I take a risk around
here it will improve fatal
but I still have to take the risk and
and and that's where the courage comes
in